canada's universities including the top
public universities like mcgill
are essentially cost free and i think
like you
attended a was it mcgill or like uh like
one of the canada's big schools
yeah no i attended mcgill which is
literally like
a fantastic school like almost for free
like a couple thousand dollars a year or
whatever um and
i'm deeply grateful for that even just
because you can kind of
not know your major going in and stuff
like i feel like in america if you make
the wrong choice
with your major or career like it's it
can be like a hundreds of thousands
of dollars mistake thousands of dollars
yeah it's true
yes so it's like i mean that's just i i
i don't know i kind of didn't fully
comprehend the situation till i came to
america and
met people and i was like damn like i
got to like try out a few different
things before i
you know chose my major so i think this
is
one of the main reasons we think canada
is more rational is that
your education is paid for and you're
not taking 18 19 year olds
and loading them up with debt and then
stressing them out about making
life decisions where they should be
exploring
yeah i mean i like did not know what i
wanted to do at 18 or 19. like
absolutely not
um you know so uh well actually i did
want to be a musician but
um i didn't think that was a reasonable
career path to pursue
um so it ended up working out but yeah i
know it's like it just seems
crazy that you should be saddled with an
insane amount of debt for decisions
you're making
before you even really know who you are
before your brain is fully wired
seriously
it's highly nonsensical and people are
paying for it here
so you knew you wanted to be a musician
did you have a sense of the medium
like uh did you think i i'm i know it's
going to be
electronic or like you know uh you'd be
the vocalist or did you dabble with
instruments or
what was the story there um i actually
never made music because i didn't think
i could or
should um and then but i was just like
an obsessive music fan like super super
super obsessive
um and then actually in my neuroscience
course or i was in a
uh i was sort of studying music in the
brain
and we actually had a class where we had
to learn logic and like make a song
overnight and bring a song to class the
next day to prove we'd like learned the
um audio recording software um and
that's when i
kind of started making music because i i
like
yeah the class provided free audio
software and then i just sort of like
went down the rabbit hole
whoa that is wild uh so what
what year uh in college is that how old
are you
that would have probably been 2009 or
2010 um and then
i basically the first music i made kind
of went viral
uh which was both both a blessing and a
curse
because like there's a lot of footage of
me like
literally learning how to make music
i've been making music for less than a
year and i'm like on stage and stuff
there's some yeah um pretty awkward
awkward video of me like being like ah i
accidentally turned
the uh sp404 off sorry guys and people
but um yeah so
well well certainly at that point your
career starts taking off and you're and
uh you end up making a career move which
anyone would have in
in your uh position i think the most
fascinating thing about your music is
that
it really feels like you're transported
to another world like i actually
have you actually listened to my music i
have actually listened to your music but
i will confess to you guys
that like if i just listen to your music
um i feel like i'm not getting the right
experience like i feel like i have to be
watching the video
in order to be like i'm not sure how
many of your fans feel the same way
but i mean i kind of feel that way so i
don't know i'm glad you feel that way i
think yeah yeah because you're such a
visual uh artist and
that there are such striking visuals
again you feel transported to another
world for like a lot of your
your videos and songs and so i feel like
they all go together in a way that
makes them more complete like if i'm
just listening to the music in a car or
whatnot
like i you know i just feel like
although let me wait until
you know i can be someplace and you know
like watch the video on my phone
i mean i don't know if that that's uh
everyone's attitude but for whatever
reason that's the way
uh i've experienced your music i mean
i'm usually thinking of
um videos like almost all my best songs
i like i was like ooh
imagine if i'm like imagine the scene or
something um
because i direct a lot of the videos
myself or co-direct them with my brother
um and then kind of make the song around
that so um
it is i think core to the music
and speaking of the canadian government
um part of the reason
i was able to even do that in the first
place like being super small and on an
indie label was
the canadian grant system which america
is maybe too big to have
art grants i don't know but that's
another thing that i
super appreciate about being born what
what i mean i didn't know this but what
an incredible story you're like the
product of the public education system
and then you had some kind of
art grants to make some of your first
videos that helped
launch you um so there are programs like
that in the united states but not in the
way you're describing i don't believe
like anyone who's an artist listening
this is like i haven't seen an art grant
in my life in the united states
the people who are saying that are
generally correct
um there there is a national endowment
for the arts but it would not go to an
independent musician that's trying to
make a video
like it it might go to a museum or an
art display
um not there's anything wrong with those
things um but that that's an incredible
story
of the government coming through i know
that's why
i'm like i mean if you look at the amer
american music in general like
so many of the artists are canadian or
swedish or
whatever you know like i do think there
is you can like
see a direct correlation between the
grant system and public funding for the
arts
and you know um like
i don't know whatever the weekend bieber
it's
drake you know um yeah
i i was just at a saturday night live um
and i was hanging out with jim carrey
and it just struck me that he's another
uh super super canadian who like came
down and took over
you know showbiz so it's true like the
canadian influence is very strong
everywhere
one of the things that i found out when
i was running this entrepreneurship
organization
venture for america was that artists
have the same impact on a community's
economic development as
entrepreneurs like if a bunch of artists
move to a community and then you wait x
years that community will end up
having economic growth
new businesses revitalization in the
same way as if a group of entrepreneurs
went
and this is a major problem for the
united states because in the united
states
uh arts are treated not as an economic
driver but as something of a
luxury or frivolity uh in part because
of what you're describing where you show
up to college and then
anyone who says they're going to study
art or music would be like are you out
of your minds and
you know people people get funneled
towards quote unquote these more
practical things
um when in truth and you and i talk
about this
like in the future we have to be
investing much more energy in arts and
creativity
uh because ai and technology are going
to do a lot of like the bookkeeping and
accounting and like the practical stuff
that that that people feel like is a
safer career i mean
a lot of this stuff is going to change
pretty quickly
yeah although i do actually think
like at least music is democratizing
really fast um
in part due to the tech companies like
um
you know garageband being free on an
apple computer or whatever
um you know i i actually like i think
you can actually record like
i think like billy eilish said she
recorded her album
in her house or whatever like it is the
technology is kind of getting to a place
where
i think in uh it's just getting a lot
more democratic like you don't
it used to be that you need to be just
really [ __ ] rich or on like a label
that's gonna spend
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make an album and
um i think it's interesting because
you're just seeing the amount of artists
making music ballooning
right now um which is cool but then it's
its own
drama because i was actually just
talking to daniel ecke
who run spotify and they're like you
know there's seven million artists on
spotify or whatever
um and like they feel like they can like
maybe make it so that like a million
artists can make a living off music
um which is still about seven million
yeah yeah seven million and
probably it's gonna like double like
it's probably gonna be more than seven
million
um but i don't know like i wonder i mean
i know you're really into like ubi and
stuff like i wonder if there's ways
to like if everything is automated like
if there's
sort of ai and machines kind of like
doing almost
every sort of menial job or whatever
like is there a world in which
if companies aren't paying employees
they can like tax
they can be taxed more like because of
all the extra in theory all the extra
revenue they'd be making it while not
having to pay um
yeah yeah and like you know could that
be
like i don't know i'm actually curious
about like ubi like i haven't read that
much about it like i'm not like like i
don't know what the specifics would be
like how
it would be um accomplished or whatever
uh
i'm really passionate about a lot of
elements of this
where right now so and you know this
much better than i do and you're like an
ultra successful popular artist
but a lot of artists are dependent upon
actually performing live and touring in
order to make money make a living
you know what i mean yeah um yeah
yeah for you too i mean like you you
understand uh this better than i would
but
uh the digital royalties from like a
spotify
are really really pretty minimal even
for folks who are getting tons and tons
of
downloads and views like i forget what
the math is but it's something like uh
i don't know like a tenth of a penny or
something ridiculous
yeah like maybe you get a few cents
and so there are artists who might get
millions of downloads
uh who are struggling to get by you know
it's
like it's actually yeah it's it's pretty
insane i mean i wouldn't say it's um
just an issue with the streaming
services i think of late
the labels are a huge part of this too
um
i mean in music there's just a lot of
middlemen like you know what once you
have like
you know business management lawyer
manager
booking agent label personally i think
labels pay too much but at the same time
um you know a label is also
can also throw a lot of money down on an
artist and it can fail so it's like
i'm not really sure what the solution is
but i
i do the situation in music worries me
like i know artists that are pretty
successful
that are like broke um and that's not
right
you know like that these are folks who
are uh
people with millions millions of plays
like they're like popular artists like
so it's it's yeah um
i feel like we need to sort of like
do something about the middleman
situation but then like i don't
yeah there is a cost structure where you
have
uh an industry that came of age in a
time when there was a lot more money
flowing through because i'm old enough
to remember going to tower records and
like the cd stories and whatnot
you know that they were like buying this
a lot of times you were buying an album
for like one or two good songs too it
was like you know like that
that was like the way it's packaged um
so you do have some legacy costs
um another big problem though is that
we've conditioned consumers to pay
one uh streaming fee and that's it you
know what i mean it's like if i paid for
spotify then i want all my music for
free um and then
and then the only way you can get more
money out of them is to show up in their
town and perform
which is okay i mean now it's not okay
because no one can perform
um but i i think that they're there so
one of the solutions i had
um and you can imagine this as like
universal basic income so universal
basic incomes government
giving everyone money and if we did that
then musicians would make more music and
they wouldn't be starving to death and
people would have more money to
patronize them
and and support them um but i think the
move we have to make
is something where we empower consumers
to pay artists directly just by
virtue of listening to them or having
their attention like every
american has like a hundred music books
or media books
that they have in any given month and
and by virtue of them listening to you
you actually get
maybe whatever the streaming like you
know pennies are but you get like a
micro fraction of that person's music
books
for that month times all of the folks
that listen to it and then all of a
sudden the
money that goes to these seven million
artists in spotify like goes up
significantly
this is like a revved up version of
these public grants you're talking about
where instead of giving it to the artist
we give it to the consumer so that when
the consumer uh
listens to a musician or supports a
musician then the musician gets rewarded
like you would need some kind of
system like that which is actually very
doable like you know it's much more
doable now than it would have been in
another time
yeah or even you know i was listening to
a podcast do you know the revolutions
podcast
mike duncan um i don't listen to it but
i i've heard it's
it's an incredible podcast um but you
know it's like he he seems so like
stressed it's always just and like
harry's razors and all this and i'm like
why can't there just be a donate a
dollar like why can't i just buy yes
just donate the dollar and like watching
artists scramble for this stuff too and
be like hey support me on patreon
support me on this and that
it's like you know it's like if i enjoy
your stuff you should just be getting
value from me
i just feel like every streaming like
every single streaming
service like even like youtube or
whatever spotify there should just be a
little thing at the side of like the
song
cast or the video and it's like i just
want to donate a dollar to this because
another thing i was thinking about a lot
is
music videos for example i know you want
to talk about kpop
which i think is sort of anyway so like
the music video master class
at the moment but um they've taken it to
a whole other level it actually reminds
me of your stuff where it's very
transporting but go on
um but you know it's like so music
videos there isn't a direct
um uh you don't directly
profit from a music video you like pay
for a music video and you just like
hope to god like it makes the song take
off or whatever
and that you can like earn the money
back on the video and like i think this
is
it's kind of sad because it's like i
feel think the art of music videos would
be respected more
um if like you could pay for them in an
easier way like when i see a [ __ ]
fantastic music video i'm like damn like
why can't i just give them
two bucks or five bucks like you know um
there are so many problems that are tied
into this but one problem is that our
attention is being monetized in various
ways we're conditioned not to pay
but then we pay this hidden price
because you're selling ads and you're
selling my data and you're doing all
this stuff yeah yeah like particularly
social media world
i mean a lot of this music we're talking
about on youtube like
freaking you know youtube tries to
monetize us through ads
and they've got very effective
algorithms and rabbit holes
and and some of that stuff's not great
you know like there's a joke that
you're always three clicks away from a
conspiracy theory on your
youtube like you'll start out watching a
video then you'll wind up
you know watching some crazy video about
pizzerias or whatever thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you